das was ich gleich mache will ich nicht
machen
ich mache es aber trotzdem denn wir
schauen uns lebensmittel machen mich
geil teil 3 an
ja kommt werfen erstmal weg in die
kommentare und wir wissen doch alle was
das offene ende bedeutet fremdscham
nutzt sich als hilfe ich muss hier weg
button dieser lars war zu lange in
quarantäne prozent wie prinz soll es
sein hilf mir ja ich weiß nicht was
schlimmer ist die stille die das essen
beschreibt oder dass ich mir das
anschaue
du kannst du das siehst mach dich auf
was gefasst und ja das mache ich und ja
wir starten jetzt mit der folge der
ausbildung zum kfz mechatroniker abbau
der hat er hat sich warten
der hat sich jetzt woanders beworben der
hat ja weil er hat er in den letzten
folgen hat er hat wird sprachen lernen
[Musik]
frau
ich glaubte er wird gerade abgelehnt
nein nein nein
das ist übrigens las und las steht auf
lebensmittel in den letzten beiden
folgen hat lassen noch bei irgendeinem
lebensmittel lieferdienst gearbeitet
aber ich glaube dass er sich jetzt
tatsächlich nach einem neuen job
umschauen allerdings hat ja wir bereits
gesehen habe wieder abgelehnt wurde
diese stimme
warum schlägt er sich denn die ganze
zeit selber als würde das besser machen
ist anscheinend nicht stark geblieben
der lag jetzt nein ich sag's die typisch
hilfe wäre wenn in dem moment jetzt
genau die mutter reinkommen würde sieht
sich jetzt aus das sind die ich mal
lieber
er hat nur noch seine sporthose an
und jetzt sind
[Musik]
oder möchten
moment ich verlinke euch die ganze folge
wieder unten also wenn ihr euch nach
meiner reaction hier das ganze video
anschauen wollt dann kann ich nicht
empfehlen lasst sie zu viel
das heißt er hat eine vorliebe für
lebensmittel offenbar hat lars diese
neigungen trotz therapie noch nicht in
den griff bekommen vielleicht ist ein
rückfall dadurch ausgelöst dass er eine
absage auf seine bewerbung erhalten hat
das waren therapie
das habe ich jetzt aber nicht
mitbekommen
[Musik]
nötig die es mir entgegen gefallen und
dann hat die lauda das t-shirt
ausgezogen
die bediener auch mein last ein rückfall
peinlich ist er sollte sich seiner
freundin sina anvertrauen und ehrlich zu
ihr sein
nur so kann sich seinen problemen
stellen und gemeinsam mit ihr nach einer
lösung suchen
ach so recht ingrid
ingrid die heißt ingrid hildegard ingrid
hildegard die stars um sich schmeißt ihn
raus
ok krass es ist natürlich hart für das
muss doch gar nicht dass er zusammen mit
china daran ihrer wohnung gibt es ist
verständlich dass china enttäuscht ist
allerdings reagiert sie hier sehr
aggressiv für die beziehung der beiden
ist ihr verhalten nicht sehr förderlich
danke du brauchst nicht alle fünf
sekunden was sagen ihnen grid nahm ich
bin kein schlechter mensch wird jetzt
ist bei der mama wieder und sie ist auch
nicht sauer dass sonst die dusche
er hat überall buttercreme anzahl
erdbeertorte
ich verstehe die mutter nicht so ganz
mal ist sie so richtig sauer auf den und
dann ist sie wieder soviel
lieblingsessen sein lieblingsessen ist
diese linsen erbsensuppe
er hat schon wieder er ist schon erste
ich habe schon den kommentaren gelesen
dass ich mich auch was gefasst machen
sollte war dass wir so häufig wieder ich
hier ja gut erkannt wahnsinn absoluter
wahnsinn
wo hört die erste bahn seien an seinem
knie
ingrid sagt lars hat hier offensichtlich
einen erneuten rückfall sieht du verlieh
bestimmt mehr und mehr sein leben lassen
sollte dringend seine therapie
weiterführen und die kontrolle über sich
aber auch über sein gesamtes leben
wieder zu gewinnen ja ingrid audick
die beiden frauen beklagen waren war
nicht immer so hatte ich immer so muss
ich sagen wird auch so schwierigen zeit
da wir sind einer meinung seit ein paar
wochen das ist gut das ist gut und und
las du bist eh nicht mehr zu retten ich
das allerdings in jeder hilfe reaktion
von mir sage ist natürlich nichts was
ich hier irgendwie äußere et cetera pp
beleidigend gemeint oder persönlich
attackieren gemeint ich äußere mich nur
zu den schauspielern und der
geschauspielert in sachen situation
person or never und es soll niemals
irgendwie die richtige person dahinter
attackieren ich weiß ich sagte dass ich
weiß nicht recht dass aufgabe ich möchte
jedes mal sagen ich hab's möchte einer
pension was böses und wir schauen uns
die zweite an ob das ist irgendwie
eingriff krieg oder ob er sich weiter
erbst und seine gemeinden abhängig bist
du bist viel zu sensibel für einen
harten job ganz mama hat das richtige
für dich
juni kann und will ihren sohn einfach
nicht loslassen sie selbst las ständigen
manipulationen aus und ich glaube sie
hat keine ahnung wie schädigend ihr
verhalten für ihren sohn ist
dem chaos arbeiten nicht entführung ein
vor meinen kollegen ja im kino delphi
süßkram knabberzeug sofort wieder
rückfällig
eine ausnahme war ja sie damit ja torte
das ist gestresst die job absage die
außerdem ist mir alles eingepackt es
liest du nicht noch mal okay also die
mutter will dass er jetzt in so einem
chaos arbeitet von ihrem kollegen job
oder wieder auch immer der hieß und sie
meint dass der las dort keine probleme
haben wird weil das ist ja alles
eingepackt ja nicht aus dem laster
wieder eine torte aus was viele aus dem
kühlschrank entgegen springt ja es muss
sich selbst um einen job kümmern
juni muss lernen lass mir zu vertrauen
und vor allem aber auch in mehr
zuzutrauen
anderenfalls wird das nicht gelingen
sich von seiner dominanten mutter
abzunabeln sehr gut im griff
die sollen die folge gleich ingrid
nennen lebensmittel machen mich geil und
ingrid geredet auch alle fünf sekunden
dazwischen
das ist mein sohnemann der last der
serie ganz dringend einen job du hast
mir doch mal gesagt dass du kürzer
treten möchte ist und da habe ich gleich
anderen ist die gedacht war der rasen
ich habe nicht an gras sie gedacht ich
hab dich
[Musik]
ich wollte eigentlich auf pause drücken
mann der erde der der der der typ vom
kiosk will nicht dass der laster
arbeitet sondern die mutter vom lassen
menschen ganz aus qualifiziert den kann
seine kasse stellen die hatte auf der
hauptschule hatte immer nur 3
[Musik]
die instanz die ist steuerschulden von
europa gerichtet lassen der hauptschule
eine drei in mathe kann es ja mal
anfangen also da steht die kiste der
hamster messer das weiteste auf und dann
tust die sachen auspacken und die
brauchen ordentliche okay er soll jetzt
machen probearbeiten bedeutet aber erst
einmal nur mit läuft und keine
eigenverantwortlichen tätigkeiten aus es
gibt arbeitnehmer und arbeitgeber die
gelegenheit einander kennen zu lernen um
dann abschätzen zu können ob eine feste
anstellung überhaupt ausgenommen erfolg
hat wenn nicht einer meinung
ich komme gut klar mittlerweile so wir
sind so die therapeutin da nicht mit
ihr ingrid hildegard hier ich in der
mitte der lokal auch hier
christ erstmal von mama das handy über
das ist ja bei sina wenn was ist groß
zumal auf arbeit an
das ist absolut okay
die haben nicht die gerechtigkeit
ich kann nicht mehr
ich kann ich kann wirklich nicht mehr
komm wir schauen und sich bei ihr keine
chance gebe ich der folge noch das geht
so weiter
egal
[Musik]
ich bin der chef darf nur noch die
action
es fühlt sich daran als werks- und
marathon gelaufen und ich sehe aus als
wenn ich mein regal anpacken
an der stelle wird das heute wieder
jetzt allerdings auf beende meine lieben
freunde wenn euch meinen reaction ja
auch auf den dritten teil von
lebensmittel machen mich geilen von der
wundervollen hilfen in folge gefallen
hat dann das gerne einen daumen hoch und
ein video da und findet jetzt hier einen
smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
könnt ihr einen kanal kostenlos
abonnieren dadurch verpasste keine
videos mehr als mega entspannt ihr könnt
so einen ausgleichen konnte und euch
dann jeden tag zu gemüte führen wie
jetzt gerade und hier ist ein anderes
video verlinkt das könnt ihr euch jetzt
anschauen kann ich euch nicht empfehlen
aber wenn ihr nichts besseres zu tun
habt